Deadpool and Wolverine and a lot of
other X-Men are about to enter the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and things are
getting super exciting and real as we
have two plot synopses today as well as
information about that very first teaser
trailer coming for Deadpool 3 when
exactly it's going to be released now I
find it hilarious that Ryan Reynolds has
already started basically trolling
everybody when he released all of his
leaked photos that were altered by him
with Photoshop and this is basically
what Ryan Reynolds is known for and I
wouldn't be surprised at all if they
actually put some of that inside of the
actual movie Deadpool breaking the
fourth wall about filming Deadpool and
the leaks getting out that would be true
Ryan Reynolds and Deadpool fashion but
today we'll talk about when to expect
that first trailer and why their plan
for it is brilliant and of course go
over the two synopses as well and if
you're new and you want to stay up to
date on Deadpool 3 and the MCU be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and if you subscribe and
leave a comment below you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for your chance to win Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items and some
DC items as well the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month so when to expect the
Deadpool 3 teaser trailer the very first
trailer that we would get from Deadpool
3 well today's report is coming from The
Insider cryptic HD quality now I believe
this Insider has about 100% accuracy
rating mainly because they talk about
when trailers are going to be released
and run times for episodes recently
they've been posting about the run times
for Marvel Studios what if and I've done
this many times in the past as well and
I've been right about a lot of trailer
release dates and according to them we
could be getting the Deadpool 3 trailer
at the Super Bowl of 2024 so that would
be in February only a couple of months
away and this is honestly probably the
best thing that Marvel Studios could do
and something that Marvel Studios really
really needs right now now before we
dive into why this is a brilliant idea
real quick I want to talk about the new
Deadpool 3 synopsis that was released
today A lot of people are confused about
it especially hearing it come out
alongside this trailer news when to
expect the first teaser trailer for
Deadpool 3 people are kind of confused
but there is a perfectly great
explanation for this and I'll explain
why but here's what the synopsis reads
after facing some professional setbacks
while going through a midlife crisis
Wade Wilson decides to officially retire
Deadpool and be becomes a used car
salesman but when his friends family and
the whole world are at stake Deadpool
decides to bring his katas out of
retirement he recruits an unwilling and
wary Wolverine to not only fight for
their survival But ultimately their
legacy now the reason this has been
confusing a lot of people is because
most of us have been led to believe that
after the events of Deadpool 2 where
Deadpool gets Cable's time travel device
and goes around time and starts messing
with it the TVA would hunt him down and
sort of take him prisoner and that's how
he winds up at the TVA and starts
Multiverse traveling well don't worry
that's all still true this is actually
Ryan Reynolds trolling again if you
recall Ryan Reynolds did the same thing
for Deadpool 2 he released a fake
synopsis for it and keep this in mind as
well and we'll talk about this in a bit
they shot fake scenes to specifically
use for marketing material and trailers
for Deadpool 2 so they shot scenes that
they knew weren't going to make it into
the movie but they knew they were going
to put into the trailers and the
marketing materials to to mislead people
intentionally and that's basically what
they're doing here with this fake
synopsis for example here's what the
Deadpool 2 synopsis read and this was
released officially by Fox it reads
after surviving a near fatal bow Vine
attack a disfigured cafeteria Chef Wade
Wilson struggles to fulfill his dream of
becoming Mayberry's hottest bartender
while also learning to cope with his
lost sense of taste searching to regain
his spice for life as well as a flux
capacitor Wade must battle Ninjas the
yuk Uka and a pack of sexually
aggressive canines as he Journeys around
the world to discover the importance of
family friendship and flavor finding a
new taste for adventure and earning the
coveted coffee mug title of world's best
lover so this was obviously fake it had
nothing to do with Deadpool 2 it had
references to The Andy Griffith Show
Back to the Future and they basically
were just trying to throw people off
which is what they are trying to do now
but releasing the Deadpool 3 teaser
trailer at the Super Bowl letting
everybody see the first trailer for the
first time at the super bow is a
brilliant idea and it's a brilliant idea
not only for Deadpool but for Marvel as
well and I think it's a very rare
opportunity Marvel has right now because
of Deadpool specifically Deadpool has
kind of a wide audience the amazing
thing about Deadpool is that he can be a
kind of crazy one-off exception to a lot
of people there are a lot of people out
there that don't follow the typical
Marvel movies or have any interest but
they have interest in Deadpool because
of the character because of Ryan
Reynolds each Deadpool movie has been
absolutely hilarious it's gained a huge
fandom and a decent part of that fandom
is people who don't typically watch
Marvel movies but make an exception
because Deadpool and Ryan Reynolds are
so funny and of course each movie is
action-packed and now Wolverine hug
Jackman's Wolverine specifically is
going to be in the film with Deadpool
and them showing the world that anybody
who's going to be watching the Super
Bowl millions of people will greatly
increase the hype of not only Deadpool
but the Marvel Universe as a whole
there's no doubt that Marvel's in a
slump right now and I've talked to many
people that I personally know that have
said yeah I kind of stopped watching
because there was too much to watch and
I just lost interest and I think that
there's a lot of people out there like
that and a lot of people out there might
not really know what's going on at
Marvel Studios right now but if they see
that Deadpool 3 teaser trailer and the
teaser trailer is exciting enough it'll
probably jump start and reinvigorate
their love for Marvel again or at least
their curiosity as to what is going to
happen happen in this movie and with the
MCU overall especially if they show
other X-Men as well which is not out of
the picture we already know Deadpool 3
is going to be a huge multiversal film
and it's a part of the Multiverse Saga
right now right now it's a given
universes are going to collapse and
we're going to see a lot of universes
collide with each other variants are
going to happen and Shan Levy has
already stated they're not going to
ignore the previous Fox films meaning
we're going to see some Fox cameos this
is pretty much known by everybody at
this point in the fandom in the
community but to show that to the entire
world anybody who's watching the Super
Bowl and then get people talking about
it get all the news outlets talking
about it how the old X-Men are returning
how Hugman is returning how it's a new
state of Marvel that could really get
the hype going again and be really
really good for not only the Marvel
Community but the superhero Community as
well so it sounds like a pretty good
plan by Marvel Studios to release the
teaser trailer for Deadpool 3 for the
first time at the Super Bowl in February
of 2024 now like I mentioned we also
have another synopsis which is coming
again from cryptic HD quality and it's
pretty simple it says this is a
temporary short synopsis for Deadpool 3
our lovable and annoying Chatterbox
Deadpool is joined by Wolverine as both
characters step into the MCU for the
first time this may be common knowledge
to people but let's not forget that
Deadpool and Wolverine are both coming
to the actual MCU which sounds pretty
obvious but you have to remember the UN
Universe they're in right now kind of
isn't in the MCU technically since
Deadpool 3 is a part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and they'll be in the
fox Universe Fox universe is kind of a
part of the MCU but it's really not and
we know that not the main MCU that is
it's obviously a part of the multiversal
MCU but what this really means is that
Deadpool and Wolverine are basically
going to step into the sacred timeline I
know there's not one specific sacred
timeline anymore but they're basically
going to be in our 616 universe and
that's what people people are going to
get really excited about Deadpool and
Wolverine and the X-Men who were in a
different what they'll view as a
franchise in a universe not connected to
Iron Man Captain America Thor the Hulk
Etc both those universes are now
colliding and that's what's going to get
people really really excited that's what
has all of us really really excited but
now it's time for them to show the world
what Marvel Studios has planned and I
really hope they do it in a great way I
hope they show it really well in the
teaser trailer for Deadpool 3 I think
they're going to do it extremely well
well I trust Ryan Reynolds Hugh Jackman
Sean Levy I think they'll absolutely
crush it but let me know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
what do you think about all this news do
you think it's enough to excite millions
and millions of people and get them back
into Marvel or not let us know what you
think in the comments and please don't
forget to like this video And subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest Deadpool 3 and MCU news you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof